So, how do we determine what is driving our cancer glucose, glutamate, ethyl, for example?
Is it from certain gene variances in our genetics, or from the cheek swab testing,
or cross tabulating both, just wondering since I'm assuming that affects our diet and supplement
recommendations? So, we use the cheek swab testing to find out what's driving the cancer
because it changes. So, it's not genetic based. There can be some genetic predispositions
that you might argue with. Let's say if you have a lot of defects in your cystic pathway,
blocking the metiety in pathway, you might have excess metiety, which would be available
for use as a fuel source for a cancer. But even if person has excess metiety, it doesn't
necessarily need the cancer. It's driven by methyne. So, cancer is always just trying to find
the fuel source. It's always just trying to stay alive. So, it's not so much a genetic
factor as it is a functional factor. So, that's why it can be valuable to change up your diet. So,
even though initial testing with us showed that maybe it was, you know, mainly fed through glucose,
and we put you on a low glucose diet and low dairy diet and factors that would cause growth,
hormone increase, and such. It can change, and then it can, let's say, you go on a very low glucose
diet and you're keep your fasting blood glucose down to, let's say you got it into the 70s. If you were
doing well for a period of time, but the cancer just took off growing again, and yet your glucose is
really low, then you got to go, well, is it fine? You got your fuel source and investigate that.
So, it could change at different times. So, you always want to be looking at that as if a cancer
progresses.